hello and welcome to this video playing
donkey shot whoo yeah let's do this
play for full-scale irritation mode
chief I've going to go Knight g5 no it
happens it happens
you're thinking for quite a while that
is actually not saying that he's not
playing it can still happen
[Music]
yeah this looks like a good line for
white I think it
you can't play b5 with black but yeah
I'm just okay with normal normal-ish
play
you
yeah I'm not certain yet c5 looks a bit
early 95
why does a bit better here yeah he will
probably be able to play eform and enjoy
this space advantage
on the other hand black is some very
solid and it's worse but it's kind of
manageable
the position that I would like to have
on the board every day have just to make
it perfectly clear but I want to get
some variation like some varieties
Redwood variety and bring choices a
green scam would accept that I think is
an interesting opening but it's not
something that I really know well just
toying around a little bit with it
he won't probably take
wanted to go to before
you
it's a little bit of compensation the
before Square for the disadvantaged
space it's not enough compensation in
some way but at least it's something
okay
you
poor I'm not really accustomed
to this kind of position
he's playing it in a very slow fashion
really
not saying it's bad is just like
very slowish with age three and Roxy one
and so on
okay 93 is kind of it's a very crude
threat but my main ideas actually to
play f5 and establish that knight on e4
maybe this is possible
Bishop on B form I have some ideas to
simply take a knight come into d2 and if
at the end it is the knight on d5 let's
say against the bishop won't be - this
is not too bad at least there should be
a playable position
maybe you should play 9f 2.5
I thought the other one I went okay
night f-35 and
then play for f3
okay maybe he wants to go to d3 here I'm
not just not sure
you
when to see give up the exchange that
it seems a bit bit harsh
really okay it's still not easy it's
still not easy the night only five azam
is a strong piece and it will be strong
on C form
you
not so not so simple that would be
relatively easily better for black
without f5 on the board but yeah you
cannot have it all how to play yeah
maybe I should simply play for c5 and
try to try to start to trade
that opens up the bishop though
No
you
and I don't think it's a good idea
basically forcing him back to see form
and then I wanted to play b5
b5 can go it's also much like simple
but getting this bit of an activity you
should should be helpful
okay
Queen a3 maybe miss Kaoru k1
[Music]
anyway come on let's open this up
okay
you
okay now if I go look eh he's got night
shift for I am yeah I need to activate
the night I guess
you three stuff
no I cannot
this
I own your character when I have to do
this for 95 and then see for
i blundered dad
you
simply blundered it
95 oh man
[Music]
man that is just extremely unlucky yeah
it's just a joke to lose the game
that's really just a big joke
no maybes
win it with bet technical play where
it's just it's just a completely lost
you
you
you
threatening root xg2
you
I'm just kind of doing this too
myself losing the game is just so
friggin awful
gives me the exchange for zip and pit
before absolutely nothing Yatta
and then he then he gets Knight b6 yeah
talk about completely yeah I mean okay I
shouldn't even give him g7 of course if
that makes no sense yeah I just
blundered the Friant porn it's actually
the best move
of King be 5 I don't know it's just so
terrible losing the game is just just
terrible ok
just wind as easily
yeah I saw this which is an
should do it because if completely tides
tied up but that that would be a pain
relatively easy win and then I stumbled
into this idiotic night v6 yeah that's
crazy I mean now here it's clear that
it's tough to win probably you cannot
win anymore but losing is just so-so
like this and now he has 96 miracle move
via and I cannot stop all this yeah we
should just go anywhere ever know
something when you cannot really lose it
because he cannot promote the apron
under normal circumstances like
something that King e6 should be a draw
tonight that is a draw yeah I don't know
count and then became it is just totally
winning yes it's true for whiteman like
here you cannot do anything I mean I
should do something else and be aged and
if it's said this maybe this gives a
better better chance is relatively
speaking but it should also be lost
would be one problem yeah bets too much
okay thanks for watching